inflation is through the roof everything
is more expensive i'm going to go see my
relatives this weekend i tried to get a
hotel the prices are way way up but you
know price of groceries is up price of
gas is up
great way to hedge against inflation
physical gold right now acre will let
you
start investing in physical gold for as
little as 30 a month michael you liar
hold on don't call me a liar michael
gold is more than that i stop it don't
call me a liar acre has come up with an
ingenious plan to let you invest in
physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once you subscribe 30
bucks a month to their gold bars when
your gold stash reaches the price of
their gold bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house just this month
they introduced a 100 a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar if
you want to up the ante i have loved
investing in physical gold and physical
precious metals go visit getacregold.com
knowles right now start investing in
physical gold today
make sure you go to that url acres
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient mentioned at get
underscore acre it's a free bar of gold
getacre girl.com knowles thank you acre
gold for supporting the show
from emily dear michael i'm going to get
a little saucy here with my question
here we go i'm newly married and am very
much enjoying the honeymoon phase if
you're picking up what i'm putting down
okay okay
it's a great time
this is a family show i don't know if i
can even read this question all right
whatever i'll just that's fine
maybe close your kid's ears until you
hear this question it's a great time but
i want to have more of a dumb and
submissive bedroom feel my husband isn't
into the idea though it says it though
and he says it makes him uncomfortable
i'm not willing to give up on it but
he's very adamant it seems in not taking
a dom role should he just man up and
take the more trad role of being the
dominant one in the relationship into
the bedroom or are my wants a little
much sincerely does s m stand for saints
and mary wow that's actually
rather than being sacrilegious i think
that's that signature is actually kind
of getting to your question which is
if i've got these kind of kinky sexual
desires can that be virtuous and good
and right or is it always going to be
sinful
yes your husband is the head of
household yes he should be
confident and assertive and
trad
but you don't want it to be
you don't want it to be sadomasochism i
mean that's that's the question right s
m is it saints and mary sadomasochism is
wrong it's bad it's disordered to want
to hurt yourself
sadism or masochism rather and it's
disordered to want to hurt another
person sadism to get pleasure from the
pain of another person and it's
especially disordered to
want to get pleasure from the pain of
your wife i mean that's especially
disordered
so
i would not do that i would not feed
that particular lust or appetite
everyone's got some kinks i mean there's
no everyone's got some weird stuff that
they're into you know this is why
there's a porn for every single thing on
the internet but i don't think that it's
necessarily a good thing to
uh indulge all of that women in
particular have these fantasies this is
why
there's like chick lit right this is why
there's the romance novels and 50 shades
of grey and all of that so i'm not
saying that uh you know you can't can't
have fun and you can't have the man be a
little more assertive but i
when it gets to the point of
like i
i get a thrill out of causing you
real pain and i or i get a thrill out of
being in real pain myself
i would not i would not indulge that too
much that's
that's that is that would not be
cool with the saints and mary i would
imagine i think you know have fun have a
good time you don't need to be like
totally bland and you know
but
uh i i wouldn't i wouldn't cross that
line i don't i don't think that's i
don't think that that's just sort of
blowing off a little steam and having
fun and i think that is the sort of
vice and appetite that is that is not
going to
make you happier i think that's going to
get more extreme over time just how like
people who write in about porn they'll
say i started looking at porn and then
it i got way more extreme and weird and
eventually i was disgusted with it i
think that's kind of what happens
there which is which is why you know you
either turn your desires in a virtuous
direction or you turn them toward vice
but whichever one you do more of it's
going to be easier to do you're going to
ultimately be more inclined to do
overtime
[Music]
[Music]
you